DANIELLE PLETKA: Good morning, everybody.
Welcome to the American Enterprise Institute.
I'm Danielle Pletka. I'm the senior vice president
for foreign and defense policy studies here
at AEI. And it is really an honor for us to
welcome the director of the Center Intelligence
Agency, Mike Pompeo, to AEI for I think the
first time in this current role - in this
current role.
So I'm going to read your bio. This is something
that I don't always do. Those of you who know
me know that I tend to kind of race through.
But I sat down and looked at the director's
bio this morning, and I was really enormously
impressed. So I'm going to read it even and
embarrass you.
So sworn in as director of the CIA in January
of 2017, Mr. Pompeo was a congressman on the
House Permanent Select Committee on Intelligence
and the Committee on Energy and Commerce prior
to that. He served on the House Select Benghazi
Committee. But before that, he was in business
for himself. He headed up his own company,
and he was a graduate, the number one in his
class, from West Point. Served with the Fourth
ID and along the Iron Curtain when we still
had an Iron Curtain, although we're well on
our way back. And graduated after serving
from Harvard Law School, where he was the
head of the law review. That's pretty impressive.
So really an honor to have you serving in
our government and delighted to see it.
Now, normally, I would give you a little bit
of a rundown on what the director was going
to say, but unusually perhaps in this administration,
I have absolutely no idea. No leaks out of
the CIA. What's happened? You've imposed a
kind of a discipline on everybody that is
just heretofore unknown.
The director is going to come up here, he's
going to speak for a little while, and then
he's going to sit down with AEI's own Marc
Thiessen for a conversation with Marc and
then some questions for the audience.
So, without further ado, Mr. Director.
MIKE POMPEO: Good morning, everyone. Today
is in fact exactly one year - in a few hours,
it will be one year to the minute when I was
sworn in as the director of the CIA. It was
supposed to be the weekend before, but you
know how the Senate goes. I got held up across
the weekend.
Danielle, thanks for the kind introduction.
Marc, thanks for having me here. I thought
I'd spend a few minutes this morning talking
about that year, that year from the Central
Intelligence Agency's perspective. You know,
it's been a very different role than I had,
although I did serve on the House Oversight
Committee as you describe, Danielle, so I
have had a chance to see the CIA as a member
of Congress. And I've told my friends that
are still on the committee, it is not possible
to gain a full - the full perspective of what
the US intelligence services collectively
can do until someone gets the incredible privilege
like the one that I have to lead one of those
organizations. Nothing can possibly prepare
you for the breadth, the depth, the scope,
the scale, the magnitude of the efforts that
we undertake each and every day as the nation's
first line of defense.
You know, I go back to the president's inaugural
speech. He talked about this being the hour
for the American action. And, at the CIA,
I have tried to live that and have my team
live that. We're doers at CIA, trying to stay
on the right side of decorum, but we just
get stuff done. And I think if the American
people had the capacity to see that each and
every day - and they can't for good reason
- they too would be as proud of the men and
women who have joined the CIA as I am.
I came to quickly understand too that I wasn't
going to improve the courage of our officers,
the skill set of our officers, although we're
working diligently to take it to even the
next level. But having led two small businesses,
having been a leader in the military, I could
see that there was a bureaucracy that was
preventing them from being unleashed - from
doing the very things that they were directed,
commanded, and indeed America needed them
to do.
And so I wanted to be part of changing that
understanding. I wanted to make sure our officers
appreciated the fact that we were going to
have an expectation nearly every day that
we were going to steal secrets. It's what
espionage services do. We ask our officers
to risk their lives to steal secrets to protect
America. It's our fundamental mission. We
will never shy away from it. And we do so
aggressively and without any apology.
But it wasn't enough for me to talk about
it. We had to start to implement it. So we've
tried to do that. One of the things that we
have done - you all have seen this in every
organization you've ever been a part of. It
is true in government, but it was true in
the private sector when I led there as well.
Bureaucracies just simply slow stuff down.
Government's worse than the private sector
because the incentive systems are misaligned.
And so I led by example. Forty percent of
the decisions that were previously made by
the director of the CIA no longer are made
by me. You might say, wow, that's reckless.
I would tell you it was reckless to do it
the other way. We made careful decisions about
which pieces to keep. If it had significant
risk, cost, political, military, risked the
lives of our officers, that's important for
the director to have. If the director brought
a special knowledge to bear, if I had an experience
set or if it needed full input from all of
the intelligence community or the broader
US government, I sit as a member of the cabinet,
then I'd keep that decision.
But if it was coming to me just because I
was the next fellow on the chain of command,
then that's a mistake because I would inevitably
slow it down and I would not be in the position
to add any value to that decision-making process.
I spent a minute talking about that, my role.
I have tried to impart that same thing everywhere
in our organization. I have asked every leader
to make sure and empower the people that work
for them, and I have tried to encourage the
people that work for them to go grab that
authority. If we do that, we'll be as fast
as our adversaries.
I've told this story once before. I was sitting
in a very long meeting with some very senior
officials, and I was asked, "Boy, if we did
X, what would our adversaries do?" And I responded
by saying, "They sure as heck won't have a
meeting like this." (Laughs.) That's exactly
how it was met in the meeting too, a little
laughter and some real concern. But everyone
knew I was right as well. We need to have
a bias towards being as nimble as our adversaries.
If we don't, we will serve America poorly,
and we won't steal the secrets that our president
and our senior policymakers most need at the
most challenging times.
Here's another good example. We were forced
by circumstances on the ground to close down
one of our operations, a station. The team
came and said, "Here's what I think we're
going to lose." We all found it unacceptable.
And I gave the commander's intent. I said,
"We're going to be out, we're going to move
out of that station, we're going to set the
date, and we aren't going to lose a thing.
Go figure out a way to do it." And, remarkably
now, some months later, I can tell you that
our intelligence posture's actually equal
to where it was. We did some remarkable things,
some creative things, some things that absolutely
had real risk and continue to, but it's in
a place and on a subject about an adversary
that we simply couldn't afford to have a gap
any larger than the one that we had before
that facility went away.
I remember too - I remember when Assad used
chemical weapons against his own people. The
president called me personally and said, "Mike,
I want to know what happened there." It took
us some number of hours before we could deliver
to the president a real response, a substantive
response that could answer the key questions.
It was clear from what I'd heard from the
president he wanted to take action in response
to the chemical attack, but he needed to know
it was the regime. He needed to know that
it was in fact chemical weapons that there
were in fact used against civilians.
Those sound easy. Everyone could see the open-source
material, but we all know for a president
to act, you need more than that. We've put
together a team that amounted to the hundreds
that worked every intelligence channel. And
we were in just a short order able to deliver
to the president the three basic facts he
needed to know with the certainty that I could
stand in front of him and commit that he would
not - we would not later find that we were
wrong and that he had acted in error. And
we delivered it to him in a way that represented
the finest of what this agency does.
If I can leave one thing behind as the director
- maybe next year I can stand here and tell
you that we've even made more progress - it
would be to be as agile and as speedy as we
need to. The second thing would be is to ensure
that we continue to keep the American people's
trust. It's in law. And as I was reading in
preparation for my confirmation hearing, it
continued to strike me how much power and
authority are granted to the director of the
Central Intelligence Agency and, through that,
to our remarkable officers.
We have an obligation to do everything we
can to operate in a way that engenders the
American people's trust so that those power
and authorities remain in place. If we don't,
if we behave in ways that are lawless, if
we behave in ways that you might see in the
movies, then the American people would rightfully
take those powers, that authority, that capacity
away from us. That would be unforgivable for
an agency to find itself in that place. What
we do is simply too important.
I see it against whichever target we're working,
whether it's efforts to help the secretary
of state, the president to understand what's
going in North Korea, whether it's our efforts
to counter Iranian influence throughout the
world, whether it's work we're doing against
Russia, those authorities, that trust that
the American people have provided to us are
central to us achieving our mission.
And so days like today, which are few and
far between when I come out of Langley and
speak publicly, it's important for the American
people to understand that we operate inside
a democracy, that we respect the rule of law
deeply, that we have processes in place to
ensure that we continue to do that, and that
we are working diligently to make sure that
the people entrusted with ensuring that's
happening in clandestine space, our oversight
committees and the executive branch in which
we work are fully informed of the things we're
doing. Everyone in my organization would know
that's my imperative, my directive for them,
and I believe we're doing that in a way that
the American people ought to be incredibly
proud of.
There are a handful of stories - I may wait
for Marc to come up here, and I'll tell a
couple of them. But you should know that we
are focused on the same set of priorities
that if you had the secretary of state or
the secretary of defense or the president
standing before you today, we would be very
closely aligned. It's been in the news some.
Last year, it was remarkable CIA creativity
which has now led to our capacity to materially
impact the capacity of the American government
to interdict shipments into North Korea. We're
not quite where we need to be. Our mission
is not complete, but we have officers all
around the world working diligently to make
sure that we do everything we can to support
the US pressure campaign and to tighten the
sanctions in such a way that we have the opportunity
to prevail and achieve the American president's
mission, which is the denuclearization of
the peninsula. This is the kind of task that
the CIA was designed for. It's the kind of
task we're delivering against.
I talked last week about the fact that North
Korea's ever closer to being able to hold
America at risk. I said there was a handful
of months. I had said the same thing several
months before that. I want everyone to understand
that we are working diligently to make sure
that a year from now I can still tell you
they are several months away from having that
capacity. It's not a static time frame. There
is much effort all across the United States
government to ensure that Americans don't
have to feel at risk. We saw what happened
in Hawaii. It is an imperative - an American
national imperative that we as an intelligence
agency deliver the information to our senior
leaders such that they can resolve this issue
in a way that works for the American people.
Look, I'll pause here and take questions from
Marc and others. As we move into 2018, I want
you all to know that we're going to continue
to do remarkable things on behalf of the American
people. We aren't just focused on North Korea
and Iran. We're working diligently to solve
problems in Venezuela and problems in Africa.
Our mission set is broad. The counterterrorism
fight, which I have not yet mentioned, continues.
CIA is a central part of making sure that
policymakers understand the threat and how
best to attack it.
Frankly, I have to tell you, I came in looking
at several of these problems and realized
that, frankly, we had been whistling past
the graveyard for decades on some of these.
And you should know that when I say decades,
that is Republican presidents, Democrat presidents,
Republican Congresses of which I was a member
and members of - Democrats who were members
of our legislative branch as well. Some of
these need to be taken off the table. We need
to reduce this risk, and CIA is prepared to
do its part to ensure that those risks are
reduced and that we ultimately can stare at
these problems with fewer resources consumed
because we have actually resolved many of
them.
Marc, I look forward to our conversation.
And thank you all for being here today.
MARC THIESSEN: Thank you, Mike, for being
here at AEI. You've been a longtime friend
of the organization, and so we're proud to
have you here -
MR. POMPEO: Thanks.
MR. THIESSEN: - as one of your rare public
appearances. So there's -
MR. POMPEO: I see all these people I haven't
seen for a long time. How are you all doing?
(Laughs.)
MR. THIESSEN: So we've had a lot of people
without firsthand knowledge commentating and
writing books and otherwise about the president's
briefing practices. You brief the president
almost every day as part of the presidential
daily brief, so I'd like you, as someone with
that firsthand knowledge, to take us inside
the - and spend a little time on this - take
us inside the president's daily brief. How
does it work? How does he receive it? What
kind of a consumer of intelligence is he?
MR. POMPEO: So nearly every day, I get up,
get ready, read the material that's been presented
early in the morning, and then trundle down
from Langley to the White House. We present
the president with the most exquisite information
any policymaker would ever have the privilege
of having a chance to read. That's the mission
set every day for the analysts that prepare
the book. And it is. It's quality material.
I'm there. General McMaster is there. Director
Coates is there. I have a professional briefer
with me as well, a CIA officer who attends
the briefing as well. The vice president's
there when he's in town. That's the gang that's
usually assembled before the president.
Someone shouts, "Pompeo, you're in," and I
take a deep breath. And then we deliver it
to him with three buckets really so we will
try - and this doesn't happen each day because
the world is too varied, but each day we try
to do something that's of the moment; that
is, we'll talk about things that happened
overnight. For instance, today, you can imagine
we would have talked about what's taking place
in Afrin, Turkey, the Turks moving south out
of Syria.
And then we'll try also to talk about something
that is coming up. So, for instance, preparing
the president for his trip to Davos or a foreign
leader who's coming to visit. Or provide him
with material that we know he's going to confront
in the days or weeks ahead. And then we create
some space as well - some space to do knowledge
building for the team, strategic items, things
that wouldn't be confronted - that won't be
in the news tonight or next week, but that
we know are central to having a shared fact-based
understanding across all of the agency. And
so those would be the three types of information.
The president asks hard questions. He's deeply
engaged. We'll have rambunctious back and
forth, all aimed at making sure we're delivering
him the truth as best we understand it. He'll
ask questions from time to time that we frankly
don't have the answer to. We didn't bring
it, or we just - weren't as complete as we
need it to be. We'll go back and within a
couple of hours deliver that information as
best we can. It is a process - the process
that we go through with the president each
day is a process that it is my hope every
senior policymaker is doing with the various
briefers that we have throughout the administration.
I hope they're all consuming the information
that we're delivering. We spend a lot of money
on it in the same way that the president does.
MR. THIESSEN: You said you had some stories.
And we had talked earlier whether there was
the possibility you could declassify a few
things that had been discussed in the PDB.
But is there an example or any examples of
times where the president has pushed back
on you and pushed you to get more information
and you've been able to change the outcome
of something or, you know - and I know this
is the most sensitive debriefing there is.
MR. POMPEO: I'll give you a couple of examples.
The president was very concerned about the
humanitarian issues taking place in Yemen,
the risk of cholera and starvation that was
taking place. And he kept pushing us about
what was really taking place on hand. What
was the real layout? What was happening in
the port? What was possible given the configuration
of forces on the ground? And he pushed us
a couple -three days until we were able to
deliver him a satisfactory picture where he
then could make a decision about which of
our friends to call to try and make sure that
that problem was at least diminished or mitigated.
And there's a second example I remember, it
was a little bit before that. It was on Venezuela.
The president was dissatisfied with the description
of the situation as we had laid it out for
him. And so we kept coming back. It was some
financial issues he wanted more clarity on:
Who had the money, where was the debt, what
was the timing of that? There were multiple
pieces. The array of the Maduro and his forces
- he wanted to really understand how they
all came together so he could have a complete
picture, and it wasn't long thereafter that
the - it would have been the first or second
set of sanctions that the administration put
in place were enabled by the very intelligence
that we had delivered and he had requested.
MR. THIESSEN: So, as you know - I mean, different
presidents take the presidential daily brief
differently. President Obama didn't take it
in person more than half the time. And it
seemed like during the transition that President
Trump was going to sort of follow that model.
He said, you know, why do I need to take - get
the same people telling me the same thing
over and over again for every day for eight
years of my presidency.
MR. POMPEO: Yeah. We try to avoid that.
MR. THIESSEN: And so what are his - that's
obviously changed. So how often does he take
the presidential daily brief? Is it daily?
And what are his briefing habits?
MR. POMPEO: It's not daily, but it's near
daily. It happened today. It happened yesterday.
It will happen most days. It depends on the
president's schedule. We'll often do it when
he's traveling, too, although I don't travel
to deliver that myself. We'll have a briefer
provide it to him. It's scheduled for about
half an hour. Often goes on for 40 minutes
or so, depending on the president's schedule.
MR. THIESSEN: How did he become convinced
of the need for it?
MR. POMPEO: I think it's about value. I think
in life we all end up with our schedules shaped
by things that are proving valuable in executing
our jobs. And so the meetings that I take
today are very different than the meetings
that my predecessor took. My battle rhythm
is different than his. This president's pattern
of taking this information is different than
President Obama's. I've done a little bit
of historical reading. It's different than
President Clinton's as well.
And I think the reason he does it is because
he finds value. That is, we're able to convince
him that the facts we're delivering impact
his capacity to perform his mission. I think
the day that we can't - I think the day that
we can't deliver that would be the day that
it starts getting pushed off and other things
begin to occupy that time and space. I tell
my team as they're preparing for what it is
we're going to substantively brief - we have
a big process, an elaborate process that picks
those topics - we have to make sure that the
information we're delivering meets the threshold
for the president of the United States and
is delivered in a manner which he can grasp
sufficiently to actually be able to act upon
- to provide real value, not just data, not
just some set of random facts but real data
that he can use to formulate policy. If we
do that, I'm convinced we'll continue the
pattern that I think is serving America well
today.
MR. THIESSEN: How do you see him as a consumer
of intelligence? Is he a sophisticated consumer
of intelligence? And what do his - your interactions
with him in that setting tell you about him
as a commander-in-chief?
MR. POMPEO: I have seen 25-year intelligence
professionals receive briefings. I would tell
you that President Trump is the kind of recipient
of our information at the same level that
they are. Look, I learn a lot every day, too.
I still - you can ask me about certain places
in the world I need to get up to speed, right?
None of us come with an encyclopedic knowledge
of the world, and the world moves fast enough
that what we knew yesterday or a year ago
is of only modest interest today. Things move
awfully fast. He has the grounding for him
to be able to grasp this information in a
way that he can ask sophisticated questions
that then lead to important policy discussions.
I watch it, Marc. We'll be sitting in a National
Security Council meeting talking about a particular
topic, and he'll bring up something that I
briefed him on weeks or months ago. It could
be that he knew that before that. I'm going
to take full credit for having been the source
of that knowledge, but I've seen this time
and time again. So it's not simply the case
that this is an exercise. He's using it. He's
taking it on board, and I'm confident that
our team is delivering in a way that's delivering
value to the president and to not just him,
but to our senior policymakers as well.
MR. THIESSEN: Is the fact that so many people
underestimate him actually a valuable asset
in terms of national security? It's often
said, you know, people underestimated George
W. Bush, a C student from Yale and all the
rest, that he wasn't that smart. And he was
actually a very smart man. Is that a useful
tool in national security that people are
underestimating him?
MR. POMPEO: I don't know. Lots of us have
been underestimated many times. Just keep
plugging.
MR. THIESSEN: All right. Well, let's talk
about your leadership at the CIA. You recently
said that your goal is to make the CIA more
vicious, more aggressive, more inclined to
take risks to come directly at the threats
that America faces in the world. How are you
making the CIA more vicious, more aggressive,
and less risk averse in the fight against
terror?
MR. POMPEO: It's all about incentives. It's
all about the things that are rewarded. In
every organization I've been a part of, it
is the human condition that you respond to
the guidance, to commander's intent, the incentives
that are laid out in an organization.
So you used CT as an example. It's important.
If you say it's a priority, you'd better mean
it, and by mean it doesn't mean - it doesn't
mean just giving really good speeches about
it. It means if you care about something,
you will apply resources against it. In the
agency, that's money, people, technical skill,
other tools that we have. You will actually
take those and apply them against that problem
set.
When you operate in a constrained environment
- that is, we have a finite set of resources
- that means you have to deprioritize something
else as well. It's almost impossible to avoid
that. And we've done it. We have said, hey,
here are the things that matter most to us.
Reprioritize and we have to reshuffle that.
People see that and people then want to go
to the place where they believe the mission
set is, at least CIA officers are very much
that way. And so we've done that. We have
said, hey, here are the things that we're
going to work diligently against, and here's
the outcomes that we're going to deliver for
the president, for the country. And we have
prioritized that way.
The second thing we've done - Danielle talked
about this a little bit - I ran a company
that sold equipment to oil and gas industry
before I came to Congress. It was the last
job that I had before I ran. I worked with
companies that were drilling for oil and natural
gas - best companies in the world, smartest
engineers, most talented people, and they
drilled dry holes all the time. They didn't
cry. They didn't punish the engineer who'd
made that choice or that selection. They got
up the next morning, tried to do a little
bit better to make sure the next one returned
something. I want to create that culture here
at CIA too.
If we're going to do it right, if we're going
to do this well, we're going to have failed
missions. It is inevitable. Almost by definition
- I'm an engineer by training - almost by
definition, if you move out on the risk profile,
you will increase the number of times you
will have failure. We're going to do that.
And we're going to make sure that people aren't
punished for that, but they are rather recognized
for having been professional, for having operated
against the target set and having done something
incredibly audacious. And if it turns out
the coin just ends up tails instead of heads,
so be it. We're going to go next day and go
crush our adversary one more time.
MR. THIESSEN: That's great. Last time you
were here at AEI for when we had this kind
of a conversation, the topic was Guantanamo.
You were a congressman. You had just returned
from Guantanamo Bay, and you made the point
that far from closing -
MR. POMPEO: It seems like a long time ago.
MR. THIESSEN: It does, yeah. But you made
the point that apart from closing it, we ought
to be filling it with new people. When are
we going to get some new residents at Guantanamo
Bay? (Laughs.)
MR. POMPEO: Well, I can't answer that. One
of the glories of being the CIA director is
you're out of the policy world. Here's what
I - from my perspective now, here's what I
can say. For the CIA, what is important is
that if we're going to take down networks,
we need the opportunity to engage with individuals
whom have been pulled from the battlefield.
We need to make sure we have the time, the
space, the capacity to take onboard the information
that these individuals may well possess.
And so US government policy, if we are serious
about these fights, must reflect that. We
have to make sure that not just the CIA, but
all - but DOD and all of the others who have
a part in the counterterrorism fight have
that opportunity. And so I'm working diligently
inside the administration to make sure that
we have that. How that will play out, how
Congress will - Congress will definitely have
its say here, right? Today we have a set of
rules for interrogation purposes. We have
the Army Field Manual for detention purposes.
DOD has the authority. That seems fine to
me. But the moment I have officers come to
me and say, "Well, we missed something. We
missed an opportunity to conduct an interview
on someone who I believe had information that
could save an American life," we're going
to begin to move heaven and earth to make
sure that something like that does not ever
happen again.
MR. THIESSEN: So since President Obama ended
the CIA's interrogation program, we've captured
and interrogated very few people. We've relied
more and more on signals intelligence. But
our signals capability has been decimated
by leaks in recent years. And your predecessor,
Mike Hayden, pointed out recently that in
an age of end-to-end encryption, which is
increasingly what we're getting, signals intelligence
is going to be getting less content and more
following what he calls digital exhaust. Can
we keep the country safe without content?
And doesn't that suggest that we need to start
getting human intelligence again in a way
we haven't been?
MR. POMPEO: A lot of predicates in your question.
MR. THIESSEN: Yeah.
MR. POMPEO: And I love General Hayden. He's
a dear friend. We're still doing pretty good
collecting signals intelligence, mostly our
partner, not the CIA, but we have a small
role in that as well. But that does not foreclose
the absolute imperative that we continue to
improve our capacity to collect human intelligence.
That includes human intelligence through lots
of different forms, not the least of which
is the capacity to interview those folks who
have been pulled from the battlefields. So
there's lots of ways to collect human intelligence.
We should not put ourselves in a position
where we are - we're making decisions on the
assumption that we can't detain an interview
to improve America's information center.
MR. THIESSEN: So the Trump administration
- let's talk about North Korea. The Trump
administration obviously inherited a mess
in North Korea that, as you pointed out, has
gone - in both Republican and Democratic administration
preceding it so you could argue that for the
last 25 years, kicked the can down the road
on North Korea, and now we're out of road
and this is coming to a head.
How does North Korea's missile program jump
from a dozen unsuccessful tests a year ago
to the state that it's in right now? And is
that alarming in the sense that - are they
getting at a build rate where they can actually
will be able to overpower our ballistic missile
defense capability? And what do we do about
that?
MR. POMPEO: So I can't share much with you
about this.
MR. THIESSEN: OK.
MR. POMPEO: Other than to say this: They have
moved at a very rapid clip, make no mistake
about it. Their testing capacity has improved,
and the frequency that they have tests, which
are materially successful, has also improved,
putting them ever closer to a place where
Americans can be held at risk. I think that's
a true statement.
It is also analytically true that Kim Jong
Un will not rest with a single successful
test, right? The logical next step would be
to develop an arsenal of weapons; that is,
not one, not a showpiece, not something to
drive on a parade route on February 8, but
rather the capacity to deliver from multiple
firings of these missiles simultaneously.
And that increases the risk to America, and
that's the very mission set that President
Trump has directed the government to figure
out a way to make sure it never occurs.
MR. THIESSEN: Does the CIA assess that Kim
Jong Un is a rational actor?
MR. POMPEO: We do. We do.
MR. THIESSEN: OK. And do you think that he
believes that the Trump administration is
actually willing to use military force, because
the only way you can have a successful diplomatic
solution is if he feels the threat. And he
seems to perceive that he's untouchable because
of what he can do to Seoul and what - even
his conventional capability, much less his
emerging nuclear capability. Does he really
believe that we'd pull the trigger and do
something to threaten him?
MR. POMPEO: So we're concerned that he may
not be getting really good, accurate information.
It is not a healthy thing to be a senior leader
and bring bad news to Kim Jong Un. Tell someone
you're going to do that, and try to get life
insurance. I dare you. (Laughs.)
So we are doing - we're taking the real-world
actions that we think will make unmistakable
to Kim Jong Un that we are intent on denuclearization.
We're counting on the fact that he'll see
it. We're confident that he will. And then,
we will continue to have discussions about
how to achieve that denuclearization.
MR. THIESSEN: Can we live in a world where
Kim Jong Un has the capability to destroy
New York or Washington with a push of a button?
I mean, is that a world that we're willing
to go into?
MR. POMPEO: So that will be a decision for
the president ultimately. I think he has been
unambiguous about his view on that.
MR. THIESSEN: Is he deterrable? Is Kim deterrable,
or does he want these weapons for another
purpose? This is the debate within the people
who have watched Korea is that does he want
this for regime preservation. Or does he want
it because it gives him the freedom of action
to do things that are destabilizing in the
region?
MR. POMPEO: So we've said - the CIA has said
this publicly before. It is more than just
regime preservation that we are concerned
he will use. We talk about the nuclear risk
all the time. That gets the brunt of the world's
attention and appropriately so, but his conventional
forces alone, right, close to a million under
arms, depending on how you count them, is
no small thing.
And so we do believe that Kim Jong Un, given
these tool sets would use them for things
besides simply regime protection; that is,
to put pressure on what is his ultimate goal,
which is reunification of the peninsula under
his authority. And so we don't think it's
the case that he's simply going to use this
tool set for self-preservation. We think he'll
use it in a way that is either - call it what
you will, call it coercive - is perhaps the
best way to think about how Kim Jong Un is
prepared to potentially use these weapons.
MR. THIESSEN: There seems to be a perception
that the options in North Korea are nuclear
war or going to a deterrence strategy. And
there are options in between that. I mean,
if he's a rational actor and President Trump
decided to do something like a limited strike,
like the one he had done in Syria, would - a
rational actor would not respond the way the
Syrian regime didn't respond, right, in the
sense that it would lead to regime destruction.
So if you're a rational actor who wants to
preserve your regime, are there options to
address his capability militarily that don't
involve a nuclear war between the United States
and North Korea?
MR. POMPEO: I'm thrilled that you asked. I'm
equally happy not to answer. (Laughter.)
MR. THIESSEN: Good. All right. And, by the
way, I have to ask, and we all understand
when you can't answer. One -
MR. POMPEO: I might say this though. The American
people should know, we're working to prepare
a series of options to make sure that we can
deliver a range of things so the president
will have the full suite of possibilities.
The president is intent on delivering this
solution through diplomatic means. It is the
focus. It has been uniformly that for now
365 days. It remains so today. We are focused
like a laser on achieving that. We are equally,
at the same time, ensuring that the - if we
conclude that it is not possible, that we
present the president with a range of options
that can achieve what is his stated intention.
MR. THIESSEN: OK. Let's talk about Iran and
sort of related to North Korea. I mean, one
of the holes in the nuclear deal is old-school
compartmentalization in the sense that - assumption
that all the work on the country's nuclear
program occurs within the country. To what
extent could Iran use its - we know that there
was North Korean cooperation with Syria, for
example, in building that nuclear facility
that the Israelis took out. To what extent
could Iran use its nuclear cooperation with
North Korea to conduct illicit nuclear work
like on warhead design that would advance
the - with Iranian scientists in North Korea
that could advance their program without necessarily
our catching it or violating the JCPOA.
MR. POMPEO: It's a real risk. We think we
have a pretty good understanding of what's
taking place there today. Having said that,
I am the first person to admit that intelligence
organizations can miss important information.
These are terribly difficult problems in incredibly
tight spaces. And when you're moving information,
sometimes difficult to detect that information
is moved. And so if someone asks me, "As the
senior intelligence leader of the CIA, can
you guarantee this?" I would say, "Absolutely
not." But we're working diligently to make
sure that doesn't happen.
This actually harkens back, Marc, to your
previous question about one of the risks of
allowing the North Korean regime to continue
to have this nuclear capability. It is this
proliferation risk. It is that this technology
that they have developed and then figured
out how to manufacture at something beyond
just a museum piece - that is, some form of
production level of their capacity - would
then be proliferated elsewhere in the world.
And then, secondarily, it doesn't take too
much imagination to understand that if they
continue to have that nuclear weapon system
or if the Iranians make advancements in theirs,
that many other countries around the world
will decide "me too," right - that I want
to have one of those things that that guy
has, being very careful not to identify countries.
But you can go through the list of those who
would feel incredibly threatened and feel
that they needed to have a similar capacity
in order to defend their own national security
interests.
MR. THIESSEN: Sure. Let's talk about Vladimir
Putin for a second. So this is a guy who,
you know, who shows up a lot with his shirt
off, right? There's a famous story where he
saw Barney and told President Bush, "This
is my dog, bigger, stronger," you know. Are
these behaviors of someone who's a strong
leader or a weak leader?
MR. POMPEO: You know, our assessment of Vladimir
Putin's intentions haven't changed. He continues
to view the greatest failure of the last century
to have been the dissolution of the Soviet
Union. He is bent on returning the former
Soviet Union to its greatness and glory. That's
what he wakes up thinking about each day.
You might add being reelected as the second
thing he thinks about each day. Those are
related in some ways; that is, I think his
- he moves about the world, he is conveying
back to his domestic audience the imperial
power of the Russian people. He hasn't changed.
This administration is deeply aware that we
need to continue to push back against the
Russians everywhere we find them.
MR. THIESSEN: So let's talk a little bit about
the recent news stories about - there was
a possible mole within the CIA that resulted
in the loss of a lot of Chinese assets in
recent years, and it's hearkened back to losses
we had - you were stationed on the Iron Curtain.
We had losses of agents in the Soviet Union.
We've had a dozen or so Iranian recruits - this
is public information - in the Middle East
who have been lost.
The business of recruiting and running spies
is hard, but the record suggests that we might
not be as proficient at it as we ought to
be. Is this something that needs to get fixed?
Are we doing well? How do you assess where
we are in terms of that?
MR. POMPEO: We're never where we need to be.
I actually saw this as a member of Congress.
I came in as the director a year ago intent
on improving our capacity to protect our own
information. We should make sure that the
secrets we steal aren't re-stolen. We have
an obligation to the American people to do
that.
I've made a number of changes, one of which
is to make sure that we're providing the information
so that the Department of Justice can do its
good work at bringing these traitors to heel
in US courts. The second of which is making
sure that our organization has the resources
it needs to deliver on its counterintelligence
mission, which includes ensuring that we're
doing offensive counterintelligence; that
is, working against our adversary's services
in a way that prevents them from getting inside
of our service.
One of the first things I did - the woman
who runs out counterintelligence mission center
reports directly to me now. That was intentional,
sending a signal to two places: one, to our
adversaries, that the CIA is going to be serious
about protecting our stuff, and second, to
my workforce - you know, that the director
was personally attentive to a mission that
can fall too far down in the priority scheme.
To me, there are few things more important
than protecting our officers, our assets,
and our information.
MR. THIESSEN: It's also really hard to penetrate
groups like al Qaeda and ISIS. I mean, your
experience serving on the front lines of the
Cold War - you had Russian émigrés. It wasn't
a tribal culture in the same way. I mean,
how hard is it to - before 9/11, we had almost
no human assets. I assume we're doing better
in that way, but we've got - as al Qaeda was
pushed back, then all of a sudden ISIS emerged.
How hard is it to get human intelligence on
these terrorist networks, the Salafi Jihadi
movement?
MR. POMPEO: So they're difficult targets for
sure, but as the US government has been successful
against them in different places, whether
it was a significant set of successes in the
previous administration against al Qaeda,
as we've had significant success at taking
the caliphate away against ISIS, it provides
us real opportunities to reach in. There are
more people who decide being part of Team
America might be better than being part of
Team Jihadi. And so we are beneficiaries when
those big disruptions occur and they allow
us to collect in ways that we can't when their
force is united and we don't have any chance
to touch them.
MR. THIESSEN: So the success in Syria against
ISIS has been remarkable in terms of taking
away their physical caliphate, but it's arguably
come at a little bit of a price because we
did it with Kurdish fighters, which has caused
some tension with Turkey. We are perceived,
at least by the Sunni population in Syria,
as being at least tacitly in an alliance with
Russia and Iran in that fight against ISIS,
which pushes Sunnis away from us and toward
al Qaeda, which is sitting there waiting.
Have we been too focused on ISIS and not focused
enough on al Qaeda? And can we defeat the
global jihadi movement without bringing Sunnis
into our orbit? Can we do this with Kurds
and Russians and Iranians, or do we need a
Sunni partner on the ground that's going to
fight these guys?
MR. POMPEO: We absolutely need Sunni partners.
And I think we're working diligently to do
that. In Eastern Syria, the Department of
Defense has done good work trying to bring
the Sunnis in alongside our Kurdish partners
there as well. I think they've made real progress
there. This administration has broadly reached
out to Sunni countries all throughout the
Middle East to form coalitions against - not
only against ISIS, but against Iran as well.
And so I think we have made some substantial
progress there. If we're going to be successful
at taking down the jihadist threat, we will
absolutely need Sunni partners aiding us in
that effort.
MR. THIESSEN: What worked in Iraq during the
surge was the sons of Iraq.
MR. POMPEO: Right.
MR. THIESSEN: The fact that the Sunni tribes
came over. We were a force enabler by sending
additional troops, but it was really a Sunni
uprising against al Qaeda, which was both
a military defeat and an ideological defeat
because the Jihadists claim to be the vanguard
of the Sunni masses and so when they're rejected
by the Sunnis, it sends a signal throughout
the region. How are we doing? Are we making
any progress in getting a sons of Iraq equivalent
in Syria and in some of these other places
where we're fighting them?
MR. POMPEO: I'm just going to - I'll let others
talk about the progress that we're making
there.
MR. THIESSEN: OK.
MR. POMPEO: But you should know that the CIA
understands that. Our analytic assessment
is much in line with what you describe. It
is an absolute imperative that we achieve
that if we're going to be successful for the
long run.
MR. THIESSEN: OK. One last question, then
we're going to turn it to the audience. So
this is a question I ask all national security
policymakers when they come to AEI. So during
the 1988 presidential debates, no one asked
either candidate about Iraq. And during the
2000 presidential debates, no one asked either
candidate about al Qaeda. Yet in both those
cases, those two elements because crises that
became to dominate the presidencies of George
H. W. Bush and George W. Bush. What is the
threat that's out there - and you see these
- you see threats none of us see, but what
is the thing that worries you the most in
the world that none of us are talking about
and none of these journalists here are asking
anyone about that really could come out and
surprise us - that you worry about at night?
MR. POMPEO: The list is long. The list is
long. So we have these set of things that
would be in the national intelligence priorities
framework, and we would all know them. They'd
be in the news many days. Then there's a set
of other things that one shouldn't characterize
as second tier in spite of the fact that they're
not in the news each day. Certainly the political
risks in South America are one of them - to
make sure we get that right and that the United
States is watching what's taking place in,
frankly, every place south of our border - Mexico,
Central America, and South America.
And then the other thing that - frankly, that
the Intelligence Committee needs to get right
is that some of these threats that are real
- one of them you mentioned, al Qaeda, aren't
nation-states. So, historically, the threats
to the United States, and your - I'm looking
around the room to see how old everybody is
- your history books would have all reflected
threats from countries. What was America doing
against the threat from Yugoslavia or some
other nation-state? Today, the threats are
much more varied than that, whether it's threats
from groups like Hezbollah or al Qaeda, threats
to our information systems from groups like
Wikileaks. They don't have a flag at the UN,
and they present real threats to the United
States of America.
And so we need to make sure that our collection
- the way we think about attacking our adversaries
from an intelligence perspective - matches
that. And that means we have to go back and
fix some of the rules, some of the laws that
are designed to solve the nation-state challenge
of history.
Cyber is another vector. It's not a threat
of its own, but it is a means by which many
non-nation-state actors can inflict incredible
costs on the United States of America. We
need to make sure that we are watching those
actors in the same way we would a threat from
a traditional nation-state.
MR. THIESSEN: All right. Let's take some questions
from the audience. Ambassador Roger Noriega.
There's a microphone coming to you.
Q: Good morning. Happy to see you again.
MR. POMPEO: Hi, Roger. Good to see you, too.
Q: One of the unconventional threats that
we're confronting is transnational organized
crime. I know I've been talking to you about
this for a good long while. In the year that
you've been director, have you been - has
it been a priority of yours to put more intelligence
resources and going after the financial network
of drug traffickers and other forms of transnational
organized crime, which is now playing an active
role in the destruction of Venezuela and looking
at influencing elections in Columbia and Mexico,
where drug traffickers have a significant
interest in sowing mayhem and optimizing supply
chain of cocaine to the market here in the
United States?
MR. POMPEO: You could probably add others
to the list. I would list the Taliban as well,
who uses drug revenue to foment so much pain
on the world. We have bolstered our capacity
there - our collection capacity. We've done
that jointly with the Treasury Department,
with Secretary Mnuchin and his team, working
together to take the tradecraft that we have
historically used against networks that look
and feel very much like financial networks
and applied them against those very same networks.
There's still a long way to go, but what it
delivers for policymakers is a set of options.
Publicly what you'd see would be sanctions
options, but in other spaces it presents other
ways that we can disrupt because if we know
where the money is, we have a capability to
stop that flow. We're probably still not at
the level we need to be, but we are certainly
in a better place when we were just a short
time ago.
Q: I just want to note that one of the challenges
will be the recovery of assets. The Maduro
regime has looted about $350 billion from
Venezuela. Being able to recover those assets
and repurposing and giving them back to the
Venezuelan people to reconstruct their country
would be a priority, too.
MR. POMPEO: Thank you. There are more than
half a dozen places in the world that I can
tell you we are watching large amounts of
wealth that have been stolen from the people
of that country and our effort to identify
them, gain the capacity to take them away
from the person who has title to them today,
and then use them for US foreign policy purposes
- frankly, in most cases to try and return
them to the people from which they were looted.
MR. THIESSEN: Nick Eberstadt.
Q: Director Pompeo, how satisfied were you
with the intelligence capabilities on North
Korea that you inherited when you came to
Langley? What do you see as the unknowables?
What do you see as the things that are knowable,
but we don't know about and should?
MR. POMPEO: So when I came in, there was insufficient
focus on the problem set. It wasn't the case
that it had been ignored. It wasn't the case
that we had missed material things, but clearly
hadn't received the focus and attention that
were going to be needed to deliver for what
this administration is going to ask of the
intelligence community. So we - within weeks
of me coming here, I created a Korean mission
center, stood it up with a senior leader who
had just retired, brought him back to run
the organization that now numbers - I can
see my information security people. There's
a lot of folks working on it. (Laughter.)
We're in a much better place today than we
were 12 months ago. We are still suffering
from having gaps. Part of that is not the
intelligence community's fault per se. These
are the difficult target sets. I'll concede
that at the outset.
But it's never - it's completely inadequate
for the CIA to say, well, that's a hard problem.
Of course it's a hard problem. That's why
you pay us. And so we're making real progress
at developing a global intelligence picture
so that we can get some of those gaps filled
in so that we can understand rates of change,
so that we can understand what's happening
among the various leadership elements inside
of North Korea, so we can also see whether
the sanctions that have been put in place
are actually having an effect or sufficient
effect and an effect on whom; that is, which
sets of people inside of North Korea are being
impact and who the scofflaws are that are
preventing those things from being as effective
as they ostensibly ought to be.
There is enormous pressure that has been placed
on me. And, in turn, I have placed enormous
pressure on our team to solve the riddle,
to close each of those gaps to the maximum
extent we possibly can.
MR. THIESSEN: Martha.
Q: Hi. I want to go back to - good to see
you. I want to go back to what you said in
the beginning, that North Korea is a handful
of months away. I assume you mean having a
nuclear-tipped missile that could possibly
reach the United States. And you said you
hope we're in the same position a year from
now - that they're a few months away. Is that
good enough that in a year from now they might
still be a few months away from developing
that weapon?
MR. POMPEO: No.
Q: OK. So what did you mean by that, exactly?
MR. POMPEO: The president - that's inconsistent
with US policy, right? US policy is that we're
going to denuclearize permanently, right,
that we're going to foreclose this risk. But
it's the case, in the event we haven't gotten
there, it is still a secondary mission to
ensure that we keep them from having that
capability. And I want to say this, too: We
often focus on timelines because it's simple.
It's not the way we ought to think about it,
right? The way we ought to be think about
it is reliability.
Can they reliably deliver the pain which Kim
Jong Un wants to be able to deliver against
the United States of America? It's one thing
to be able to say, yes, it's possible. You
could - if everything went right, if the missile
flew in the right direction and we got lucky,
we could do it, as opposed to certainty, right?
This is the core of deterrence theory. You
have to be certain. In the deterrence model,
you have to be certain that what you aim to
deliver will actually be successful. At the
very least, you need to make sure your adversary
believes that - that it is certain.
That's what Kim Jong Un is driving for. He
is trying to put in our mind the reality that
he can deliver that pain to the United States
of America, and our mission is to make the
day that he can do that as far off as possible.
Q: And can I just follow up to the intel question,
and you said a couple of months away. We know
the intelligence before had it far in the
future - six months, two years, whatever,
and he was much faster than you thought. So
do you trust - do you feel you have enough
information in saying a couple of months away
to be certain? And also on the sanctions,
you said that's a gap, essentially, just now
-
MR. POMPEO: The impact of sanctions. Yes.
Yes, ma'am.
Q: The impact - the impact of sanctions. So
do you see any impact now that you trusted
also on the missile timeline?
MR. POMPEO: So I can't answer your second
question, so I'll do my best to answer your
first. It's not that I don't know. I do know.
I just can't share with you what we know on
the second question.
The first one, your predicate's actually wrong.
You said that somehow that the intelligence
community got this wrong. We didn't see this
coming as fast as - that's just untrue. I've
seen the news articles that have written that.
By the way, it's not me bragging. This all
happened before my time, all of this work.
The Intelligence Committee on this one actually
understood the capability and the testing
capacity. We'll never get the week or the
month right on something that's this complicated.
But we can get the direction of travel and
the capacity for rate of change right, and
we did.
We believe we are continuing to deliver good,
solid information on the North Korean missile
testing program and all the ancillary pieces
around it. We're pretty confident in that.
MR. THIESSEN: Let's take one more question.
In the front here. Wait for the microphone
please.
Q: Thank you, sir. I'm Janne Kum Pak with
the USA Journal. Recently, North Korea and
Kim Jong Un wants a dialogue with South Korea.
On the other hand, Kim Jong Un's nuclear threat
- continues to threat the United States with
nuclear and missiles. What is the US final
destination of resolve of the North Korean
nuclear issues, and is it possible to preemptive
strike to North Korea if necessary?
MR. POMPEO: So I'll leave to others to address
the capacity or the wisdom of preemptive strike.
From an intelligence perspective, we're trying
to ensure that all the various options that
the president might want to consider are fully
informed and we understand what's really going
on and the risks associated with each of those
decisions as best we can identify them for
him.
Let me just sort of - we're doing that in
conjunction too, right? We should remember
we have partners there that are working on
this diligently as well - the South Koreans
themselves, the Japanese. We have partners
throughout the region that share our understanding
that this is a global threat. We often here
in the States talk about the threat here.
This is a threat to the whole world.
MR. THIESSEN: OK. Ladies and gentlemen, we
have to end it here. I ask everybody to stay
seated while the director leaves. And, Director
Pompeo, I know you don't do a lot of these
things. We're hugely honored that you came
here to AEI to spend some time with us, and
thank you very much for your service to the
country.
MR. POMPEO: Thank you, Marc.